so as we pick up with our third
spider-verse video what we do here is we
pick up with Ben Riley Jessica drew and
Cain now keep in mind they've arrived on
earth one and the whole reason for this
is because they've been able to trace
the source of where these clones are
coming from the clones were originating
from this planet and when they arrived
here what they find is that this version
of Earth seems to be some sort of
technological paradise that is to say it
seems very technologically advanced it's
really kind of how you would expect to
see a future maybe utopian planet Earth
but as they begin to move around as they
begin to look around they realize things
don't necessarily seem right that of
course they're moving through the
building they've arrived in and they see
what appear to be maybe clones or some
kind of individuals who for whatever
reason are marching in a single-file and
they really don't pay any attention to
anybody else's if there's somehow
zombies or some sort and so what we do
is we see that as they're investigating
they're trying to figure things out they
ultimately come across a scientist and
the scientist sees them dress up in this
hospital garb which was their choice of
clothing in order to keep a low profile
and the scientists ask then why it is
that they're out of their groups why it
is that they've deviated from their
groups and so the scientists alerts the
guards now Kame is able to subdue the
scientists who basically I guess uses
webbing to adhere him to the ceiling and
to keep his mouth shut but for the most
part the damage has already been done we
see that these various forces show up
begin to try to overpower the Spider Men
but as they're able to take these these
soldiers out we see the Tony Stark arise
now Tony Stark tries to fight the duo
here but of course in the process Ben
Riley's knocked out and and Kaine is
able to knock out Tony Stark in turn and
so once Ben Riley comes to he began
speaking with Jessica drew again this is
just to get drew from the ultimate
universe and Jessica drew says that
she's been able to basically dismantle
the armor of Tony Stark and when she did
they began interrogating Tony Stark and
what they asked Tony Stark is what's
going on here what the what the whole
basis is behind all these things and
what he says is that this is gene X's
planet and so what happens here is that
again as they're interrogating Tony
Stark Tony Stark says that he's the one
that's responsible for a majority of the
technology that's taking place on this
planet so all we really know here
is at some point along the line genetics
appears to have somehow shown up on this
planet earth and then basically force
everybody into a state of subservience
or it could very well be that it's
always been this way we don't really
know how it is this planet came to be
the way that it is but what we do know
is that the I guess this group of
scarlet spiders that I've been Riley and
Kane and Jessica drew decide that the
only real way for them to again get this
stuff figured out is to go directly for
Gen X and so when they asked Tony Stark
where Gen X is at he says that he's in
the Baxter building and so what happens
here is we see they've been Riley that
came and Jessica drew show up at the
Baxter building but what's going on is
that came I'm sorry that Ben Riley is
apparently dressed up as as actual as
Tony Stark himself he's actually wearing
Tony Stark's armor here and the whole
basis as far as we can tell from this
plan is that that Ben Riley dressed as
Tony Stark is basically bringing these
two individuals in bringing in Jessica
drew and Kane as people that he's
captured which can be taken directly to
to to genex himself but what happens
here is there a plan is basically thrown
awry when Johnny Storm appears and
Johnny Storm is again wearing some kind
of military outfit indicative of the
kind of military outfit you would see on
this planet and it seems as though he's
working for Gen X and he asked Tony
Stark what's going on and so what we do
here is we pick up with a Peter Parker
and superior spider-man what happens
here is again both a superior spider-man
and Peter Parker are arguing over who it
is that should lead them what what
superior spider-man says is that his
team was holding on just fine Doctor
Octopus says they were doing alright
they were finding a way to to keep
themselves mass from the inheritors they
were putting plans together and then
Peter Parker's team stumbled in and by
virtue they had brought silk and because
they had broad silk they had drawn the
inheritors to them and so what superior
spider-man is basically saying here is
that Peter Parker is inept as a leader
he doesn't really know what he's doing
and because of that he really shouldn't
be a leader but again we continue seeing
them going about we continue to see them
argue but we see the Peter Parker
realizing that he is basically the
previous version of himself that is to
say he is in possession of his body
before Doctor Octopus takes it over
basically calls doctor octopus's Bluff
fury call superior spider-man's Bluff I
need to tell superior spider-man to kill
him but superior spider-man says that he
can't the reason being because if he did
it would create a paradox
superior spider-man was simply just
ceased to exist and so while superior
spider-man is distracted here Peter
Parker knocks them unconscious and so
what we do is we transition back to the
home of the inheritors for a moment and
we see that solace and more lune are
speaking with one another and what
they're doing is they're talking about
this prophecy and in relation to this
prophecy what they're saying here is
that three new pieces have appeared on
the board the other the bride and the
Scion and again we know the other
appears to be Cain we know that that was
established during the early events of
the spider-verse continuity but we also
know that the bride is is silk what we
don't know here again is who the Scion
is but we're going to find at the end of
this arc or the end of this story the
end of this video is that the Scion is
somebody we've seen this entire time but
what we do is we see that as the two of
them are again talking that solace is
really kind of fed up with what's been
going on here he's really kind of been
fed up without basically toying around
with these different Spider Man Spider
women's so what he does is he tell us
more loon together geniux and that the
three of them are going to go after all
these different spiders in the safe zone
and so what happens is we jump back to
the safe zone and we pick up again with
Peter Parker and superior spider-man
then what's happening here is a two of
them have basically come to terms I
wouldn't go as far as to say that
they're on the same wavelength but at
the very least they understand the
necessity of there to be a leader and
the Peter Parker has basically
established himself as being a more
capable leader than the superior
spider-man here and so what happens is
they begin to discuss and they begin
talking about the open nature of this
safe zone and what superior spider-man
says is they have to find some other
place to go they have to find some other
place to to travel to simply because of
the fact that they're far too open here
and so what spider-man does is he agrees
and he begins calling out to the other
groups who have transitioned to their
own stories of course to Spider Woman -
to the Scrat spiders to spider-man 2099
now Peter doesn't initially get a
response from either Kane or Ben Riley
and in fact this is a little
disconcerting to him and the reason why
is because if they're not answering
their communicators then the possibility
exists that they've been killed in
action they are in fact dead but of
course Peter doesn't necessarily
acknowledge this as the most guaranteed
thing because again it would tie in to
the fact that things are getting
relatively hopeless here and so what do
we see is that he calls out to McGill
O'Hara
yellow Harris says that they're
continuing to try to find a place to I
guess to tap in and to autopsy this body
of damos again trying to escape back to
a safe zone here but we also find out
from spider-man UK is that Spider Woman
that Jessica drew has chimed in and told
them that Spiderman waar is apparently
out of commission and so what Peter
Parker says is that he's going to take
one of the cloaking devices from
superior spider-man and he's going to
take it to spider-man waar for a couple
reasons
the first reason is because it would
allow him to stay hidden it would allow
him to stay away but this is due to the
fact that because the inheritors have
already visited the spider-man noir
universe when they first came into
contact and we were first introduced to
spider-man noir as part of the edge of
spider-verse and the build-up to the
spider-verse story he says they're most
likely not going to come back and so
most likely it'll be safe for a
spider-man waar as long as no one knows
he's there but what he also asks is if
there's a way to read I guess we virtual
engineer this particular cloaking device
because again these are things that have
been created and tampered with at the
hands of superior spider-man that who
previously belonged to the inheritors
and superior spider-man says that he's
already modified this device and he's
already traced its origin back to the
homeworld of the inheritors which is a
place they could travel to if they
wanted but the problem is that if they
all decided to go after the inheritors
in their home world it would be a
massacre because they're simply just not
prepared for that and so what he says is
that he has a plan and that this plan is
going to involve him taking spider-gwen
as well as anya back to the spider-man
to our universe - most likely grab
Jessica drew and the reason for this is
because they need someone who can go to
the homeworld of the inheritors and to
find out what it is they're doing there
to basically be their eyes and ears to
gain information and then report that
information back and so what we do is we
continue with this is we see that he
also sends Miles Morales as well as
spider-man from the Ultimate Universe
cartoon show to the - then I guess an
alternate reality to various alternate
realities and the reason why is
spider-man explains is because they need
to again continue the effort of
gathering as many forces as they can to
bolster their ranks and so as the groups
begin to splinter off as they begin to
leave we find that solace and more loon
and Gen X arrive and what solace does is
he begins basically taunting the other
spider-man
breakers but we also see jinx and more
loon doing the same thing now of course
cosmic spider-man appears and tells them
that they were fools to come there that
there's no way they can stand against
the stand against the might of cosmic
spider-man but what solace says is that
the enigma force the power force that
cosmic spider-man wields is basically
pure life energy which is exactly what
him and his ilk feed on and so what he
says is that while the other members of
his family may not be able to withstand
the full might of the enigma force that
he Curtis certainly can and so what he
does is he absorbs the life energy of
cosmic spider-man killing cosmic
spider-man and the process and so as it
stands the other spider-man characters
here are virtually defenseless they have
no safe haven there's really nowhere
they can go to now and so of course they
begin panicking they begin taking off
trying to find places to go to but what
we also find is that while Gen X is
killed in the process that more loon is
able to locate the Sion and the Sion is
revealed to us to be the I guess the
baby brother of made a Parker the child
Benji with that being said we're going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates from comics explained and
talk to me directly
far away I
my